[Music]
no it's okay I'll wait coined it welcome
back to the podcast guys this episode is
brought to you by this skim get in the
know with everything going on in the
world in a really easy and convenient
way by signing up for the skim it's a
great newsletter that packs all the
information that you need to know about
news and current events and what's going
on in the world into a nice short
concise beautiful bite-sized the email
and it's completely free so go to the
skim that's th es que IMM comm / channel
Julian enter your email click Subscribe
and that's it you're done it's free also
when you do that you are entered to win
a $250 Visa gift card you can spend your
money doll or somewhat ever you feel
like spending it on also guys thread up
if you're trying to get some amazing
brand clothing and you want up to 90%
off thread up is for you okay it's the
way it's the way you can upgrade your
wardrobe on a budget go to THR edu P
comm thread up comm slash Jenna Julian
and you get an extra 30% discount on us
okay it is an incredible secondhand way
to be shopping some of the top name
brands you can ever find or want at a
really great price there you go thank
you sponsors you're welcome you're not a
sponsor who sponsor part of the podcast
sponsor so we've come to the final
episode of the year oh my god which
means we're wearing medicine me on these
ones yeah we're wearing the matching me
and these onesies and they sent us which
sponsored this week we want to also
thank all of our sponsors through the
entire year
I think all of you guys for listening to
genuine podcasts for whatever reason
from another year it's one of the most
surprising things how much you guys
enjoy the podcast I mean it's certainly
fun to make it's fun to make but that
doesn't mean that I expected it to be
totally it would be enjoyable to listen
to or that anyone would like it like we
started it just for whatever you know
because we were live streaming and then
we're like maybe you should record this
into a podcast but we are and it's gone
through many iterations and sets we
don't like who knows if this is its
final form you have no idea
oh it's not definitely not knowing me
it's not I'm gonna alter something at
some point get a hug later yeah no I'm
definitely gonna probably paint the you
know a little more thing with that
please do not paint any ceilings in this
house I'm gonna I'm gonna paint this
ceilings a little bit okay no just in
case we want to do a top-down podcast we
can just look down at the camera it'll
be up and the green-screen will still
work it'll be like an egg selfie before
a whole podcast is that like how we
talked about having a guest just float
back here yeah okay you know actually
Kermit as much as I want you to go in
your bed and please be silent a lot of
people requested that you just cry into
the mic for an hour okay pick him up
he's not gonna cry Kermit at some point
we can get you crying for an hour if
people want an hour-long audio of Carmen
crying lik I don't I don't see why we
can't just gonna do audio I mean if
we're going to the length of producing a
show of him crying it's gonna be a video
and audio the car mate crying screaming
crying sure it won't be an hour straight
of crying it will be a clip show of an
hour long of Kermit crying yeah yeah hey
no no you're the good Iggy okay you need
to go be good you're the blonde nice one
not the nasty rat one okay
well twenty eighteen twenty eighteen so
a lot of you wanted us to sort of recap
there's like a lot of requests to just
be like recap 2018 your favorite
or anything and we can do that we can
kind of go through the year a little bit
we just you know there was a lot of good
things that happened this year there was
a lot of whatever things and not so
great things that happen this year and
also like I think recapping in a way
that's just like conversational is kind
of good because it's just like talking
about the year but back to what we were
talking about I was like that the fact
that we're still doing this mm-hmm
four plus years later or whatever and
you guys are still watching it's still
really fun and it's still really fun but
like I don't know cuz I I've listened to
podcast and I've know I felt the feeling
that you guys explain when you're like
oh I love hearing you guys talk but it's
still insane to me that we're sitting
here and this conversation gets shared
every week I don't know I mean
so I laughed pretty hard in the podcast
like it's a unique opportunity for us to
sit and talk to each other and make each
other laugh it's kind of what is there
anything a little bit like your contest
who can make well you're definitely
winning cuz I sit here and like scream
laughing at you well I've been I've been
kind of catching a little fire the last
couple episodes not gonna lie
feeling good you know heating up I will
say that one of my favorite podcasts
that we did this year was the movie
music trivia that was a pretty legend I
think pretty great moments in there that
was like the inception one Robin Bush
edited that one mm-hmm
yeah that was a good podcast and we were
dancing to Tokyo Drift and all that it
was great
I didn't know his Tokyo Drift I know
that song will forever haunt me I think
that we took some good risks this year
like trying to sing a song with the note
that you think it is before you play it
like I don't I don't listen to like a
million podcast but like I'm not sure
that there's a ton of podcasts out there
that do quite the nonsense that exists
no no and that's what I pride myself in
being a part of this podcast is that
we're pushing the limits of nonsense
what people think exists in the nonsense
community we're pushing those limits
every week we made a show called mild
ones mm-hmm not hot ones
yeah mild ones was good I think we
should look part three 100% original
ya know it's our idea I Pat I file the
patent they haven't gotten back to me
for whatever reason are you patented
yeah I patented the show where you
interview someone while eating hot wings
I don't know why they didn't get back to
me on that patent how can you patent the
show maybe that's why they didn't get
back to me or because that little show
already exists called hot ones by Sean
Evans but I want to do a part three of
hot ones I want to do with a guest hmm
and get even hotter sauce I'll tackle
their sauce I'm talking two million
Scoville I'm talking like you regret
waking up that day okay here here's
here's an idea for mild ones okay okay
we start with really hot wings just like
we've soaked to this like vegan chicken
wing in water and it's just bland as
hell so you start with the hottest and
then you work your way to no sauce
mm-hmm
called Milan mouth once that's actually
how maudlin should be okay coming in to
forget the first two episodes they don't
know had they don't exist anymore
yeah mild ones coming for real in 2019
where we start with boiling hot hot
sauce and go backwards to really bland
ones club says he wants to make us like
a graphic like a do not do not start
call calling Caleb club club
no yeah yeah no he wants make us a video
graphic symbols
don't call him club club his name is
Club I'm sorry everyone out there named
Caleb if your name is Caleb your names
now club Congrats and you're welcome let
me know if you want to help me spelling
out I'll help you yeah no it's Club fine
then you do I'm Jude you like June's
kitchen kitchen is a cool name I like
June it's just straight to the point
cuts out everything in my name that's
extraneous Leah Leah no get rid of that
it's just fine I'm gonna start calling
you lien
that's the part I don't like me and now
I'm not Liam Liam Liam no Liam Liam
Leon I recall you n why cuz that's part
of your name mmm-hmm
hey not really are you put in the nod
yeah
do you know that woman at the beach
supply store names namaste
oh you know she's great she's great she
always helps us with our projects yeah
because we walk in there and she just
looks at both of us and starts laughing
and like what are you guys this is like
okay what what what do you need today
and just like it's like the funniest
part of her day for sure us going in to
the beauty supply store I think that
that takes a level of hubris to say what
do you know what the funniest part of
nas's day is um I know because she's
told me she said one time I walked in
she's like I just need you to know that
every time you walk into my store you
are the funniest part of it and also
maybe tell the story in the podcast
that's what she said that absolutely
never happened Jillian
you wouldn't know I've been there
without you before oh really
will you die Jason's there me Jeff and
Jason went there you went to oh that's
right oz was there I had 12 missed phone
calls even though I literally told you
exactly what to buy no you were like
yeah get the primer or whatever that
what is the thing that lifts out and
look at this
yeah no not bleach the thing that you
put in lifter lifter get 12 lifter 0.5
minus 0 degrees of the mystery flavor
and then get the color of shade point $5
yeah so I tried to do that and not just
like basically did it did everything for
me speaking of which I want to dye my
hair I kind of want to dye it red but I
like haven't found a shade of red that I
want to totally unrelated okay we're
just we're on this Aries roller coaster
together we'll follow your train of
thought I feel personally attacked on my
own roller coaster I feel attacked by
the way we were facetiming with Chris
and Shan and Shan she's an Aries tattoo
and I realized I need an Aries tattoo
but I need it to be way more of an Aries
tattoo than hers hers is a very small
area symbol see Julian
here's the thing he's a big big I
understand how we just got to the idea
of you having a big loud flying area
said to but like it it was like kind of
a little bit of a roller coaster getting
there like I'm following you it's not
out of the blue but like we are on an
Aries roller coaster how hard is it to
follow a roller coaster if you buckle in
you're just on it
you don't have to follow anything it's
not like driving you get on the roller
coaster like willingly and are like
super pumped about it sometimes I feel
like I'm being held hostage
no no really goes welcome to the hostage
coaster 2k 18 it's the craziest roller
coaster that you never wanted to be on
welcome to be the hostage coaster 2019
because this is the end of 2018 this is
the last podcast of the year because
next week we're taking off take
Christmas in New Year's off last you
know I actually don't think if I'm right
I don't think we've taken Chris
Christmas in New Year's off the podcast
ever
we were we were planning on it last year
I don't know what happened this year we
were taking two weeks off with the
podcast and I know that's a long break
and trust us we're gonna miss the
podcast like we we do Monday mornings
getting the tweets in the comments and
like seeing guys engage it's the best I
love it and like recording them is the
best but we are gonna take some time for
the holidays with our family with your
family with you know my family's comedy
we're turning off the internet for a
little bit and I think it'll be great
because we're gonna we're gonna come
back in 2019 refreshed I will still be
in Aries you will still be on the
hostage hostage coaster but it'll be a
new year we'll have a little bit of
rejuvenation going on but yeah anyway
this is the last episode of there so if
you're wondering where we are next week
and the week after just know that the
podcast has officially ended forever and
I'm totally worried about it Oh sick
what was your favorite movie this year
cuz I think I only saw like one or two
my favorite movie yeah I don't you you
don't like the movie theater so we we
just kind of I feel like it only
exclusively watch films on planes at
this point yeah that's fair the only
place that's fair I watched gone girl
this year
hmm that was not a new movie though no I
watched it this year though did you like
it feels good it's a pretty gory scene
there in the end he's my blood stalker
vibes only stalker did you like it
though yeah it was good yeah wasn't
anything to run home about but it was
good I saw Coco
we saw Coco Coco is good coke so
therefore it was my favorite movie of
2018 because it was one of the only ones
that I saw
was my own age I saw a Wonder Woman no
you oh you did while I was gone didn't
you no wait on the plane to Hong Kong oh
that's right
you watched would you watch while I was
out of town Casablanca that's your
favorite movie or 28 yeah we talked
about it yeah yes oh I forgot to tell
the podcast so like after that I was
really nervous that everyone's gonna
hate me for my opinion on hating
Casablanca because one time Julian was
out of town I watched it when I was
drunk and I hated every second of it or
if you want to watch that podcast I
talked about it like I didn't hate it
it's complicated but so another time
when Julian was on LMT I was like all
right I'm drinking some Pinot Grigio
beet it's getting free late you know
what I'm gonna watch is gone with the
winds because the girl has not seen it
so I couldn't find it on any platform
except for Amazon video which then I
couldn't figure I was getting drunk at
this point so I couldn't figure out how
to put it on the TV so I was watching it
on my cell phone
sure yeah and it's a little bit
complicated to watch a film like that on
your phone while also trying to drink
Pinot Grigio and I just started laughing
really hard and I just couldn't finish
it I've got like five minutes in and I
was like you know what I think I missed
the sweet spot of like having a glass
and watching this or two glasses and
watching this and like it's not gonna
happen tonight that's toxic I'm but I
will say that in 2019 I would love to
have a couple of glasses of Pinot Grigio
watch gone with the wind in or other
movies of that era and give you my
honest opinions on them because I loved
that how do you entertaining like the
way that I felt about Wonder Woman was
pretty similar to it I don't I don't
know if I said that on the podcast I
just remember saying it to you in Hong
Kong yeah is it like I feel like a bad
woman that I didn't really like that was
the one with gal gadot right mm-hmm
there's a scene where she's running into
things being shot at her
and it's blocking the bullets the many
many so God are we gonna talk about that
no no no I'm just saying I have a 20-19
has I finally let my horrible awful
uninformed and yet a little like I'm not
trying to do any harm but like I just
don't like a lot of films that other
people seem to enjoy fair enough
but that's true about you I can confirm
that I watched Black Panther this year
that was a great movie
I'd legit don't go to the theaters
anymore I saw Black Panther I saw that
on the plane you fell asleep no no I
finished it are you finished
yeah what do you think was like a
12-hour flight that's for you yeah you
fall asleep and then you rewind it and
finish it yeah you know what's good I
you know I I truly you know I know how
knowing this is to hear but I truly
think that was the movie you see in
theaters to get the real yeah vibe and
experience of it which is you know I
just I didn't see like Infinity Ward I
didn't see any of that nobody Star Wars
no I I feel like a bad movie goer but at
the same time I consumed a happy amount
of content for me on on what I watched
like with the TV shows i watch like
Handmaid's Tale better call Saul
West world we finished this year just
everything we watched and all the online
consumer watch i'm i'm nearing the end
of Seinfeld not really I'm like I'm
working my way through Seinfeld you're
you're missing a lot of episodes cuz you
keep falling no I'm not every time I
fall asleep the next day I go back to
the one where I remember the last moment
before I doze off I think you're missing
like a couple of seasons no I'm not I'm
truly caught up I know for a fact you
can you know what how about this what
happens on the mountain seasons have an
episode five quiz me on anything up
until 7.5 I'll get it right nailed it
dude
promise I don't I don't I don't want to
do that right now no not right now but
like just in general like in private
will turn off the lights and just quiz
me what I'm in the know okay I know
things just like you would if you read
this game every morning yeah no scam
newsletter it's a free newsletter sent
to your email
guys what a better way to get your
information you don't have to scroll
through anything you don't have to
type anything you'll have to Google
anything you have to ask Siri your
Google or Alexa no the skin is just like
here bla bla bla
[Laughter]
they're reading the blah blah blah
they're not saying it they're like okay
logic logic logic concise concise
concise and then they send it to you of
the Jenna and Julian podcast this I'm so
sorry then you're like wow the skim you
really just made all this so easy to
digest and you highlighted the most
important things going on in the world
like I can't dude dude simple it is to
know things now I don't have to do
anything work myself the skin is
literally doing that for me it's so easy
a mediocre save but I appreciate it was
a great save it was a great save like a
legendary and it's free did I mention
that it doesn't cost a single dollar or
penny or euro or peso or yen or euro
they say euro ruble that is currency an
escape from tarkov I'm done with this
Segway go to the skin calm that's th es
ki n em calm slash Jenna Julianne it's a
Russian currency though isn't it yes
tarkoff is based in Russian no I know it
is oh sorry guys you'll be in great
company ok because Sarah Jessica Parker
loves the skin and when you click the
link below or go to the Kermit that's a
big machine that you can't touch with
your long rat feet can you get them off
the table he's gonna cancel the whole
podcast Julian that's the next show you
can watch your enter to win a visa $250
Visa gift card and if you wanted what
were you gonna say next show that you
can get into is Sex in the City they
were a lot of designer clothes on that
don't they you can get your designer
clothes when you go to thread up guys it
is up to 90% off retail price of the
world's like a best most desired
name-brand clothing it is the wait a
second hand shop a lot of the clothes
that you're gonna get with right up
still even have the tags on them that is
how good condition they are
you have the selection so so large that
you're gonna wonder why you hadn't gone
to thread up earlier they have a lot of
what are you doing I'm trying to focus
here okay if you want to look like you
star in Sex in the City which is a
current show right over every day film
if you want to look like your week is
the new sex and this is here a cast
member in the new 2019 version of Sex
and the City go to thread up guys they
have like Banana Republic anthropology
like oh come on dude I could go on and
on
actually a lot of you have sent us
pictures of your halls from thread up
which is really cool because you're
getting an awesome deal and that makes
us happy that you're saving money on
clothes and you don't have to spend a
lot of money on clothes and feel guilty
so right now go to thread up that's thr
edu P comm slash Jenna Julianne you'll
get an extra 30% off on top of all the
discounts they already have it is worth
a shot check you guys click the link
below and do you just get in to just get
styling real quick for a really really
good price thank you sponsors what do
you doing over there it's not going
breathe yeah yeah we were talking Kong
this year I was pretty crazy was it was
a very good time we bought a house this
year we bought a house something that
only goal and it's been just absolutely
wonderful and we've been dealing with
all of the the lovely things that come
with being a homeowner but like we're
doing are so fun yeah anymore
yes pretty good pretty good
I think a big highlight for me this year
was twitchcon and playing in the
broadcast royale so what a cool
experience that was what a cool
experience that was brought to you by
like pub G in our life like it is so
cool the amount of things that we've
gotten to do and just the experiences
we've had with one video game that we
didn't know about before
a year and a half two years ago I agree
and I feel like a lot of people have
been asking me within the last couple of
years since we've been on Twitch more I
guess than we were you know four years
ago you know like Eric when he was
talking to me about like you know do you
ever juggle for five years or like do
you ever like feel weird about where
your life is at or like do you ever plan
anything you just like go where the wind
blows dude I'm like listen okay I'm a 32
year old lady and I just played in a
live land set up video game tournament
okay if I had a plan if I was like
sitting around and planning my life we
would never be here you know what I mean
like letting the wind sort of blow you
and go where you want to go and what
seems like a good fun time and what you
enjoy is like how I've always lived my
life and it's just like it's kind of
amazing to think that I'm you know
someone my age sitting at a computer
absolutely loving playing video games
like that I never had in a way like that
before you know and if I was you know
not that there's anything wrong with
making plans for your life or anything
like that like I just think that if I
had if I was like in a different mindset
I wouldn't have ever been here it's not
another place I would ever be and it's
just been so enjoyable you know I agree
100% and it's like this it's this worlds
colliding of like our hobby and work
right like we're like we're doing it all
the time because we're incentivized to
do it for work but at the same time it's
like we love it it's so fun we love it
like the other day it was the when we
were taking care of marbles we couldn't
game that night and he was like a
weeknight where we normally stream but
instead we weren't streaming and we like
cooked dinner and we like hung out with
the dog and the night was going so slow
but in like a really great way and I was
like holy crap dude our nights go by so
fast now because we just get on the on
the PCs and we're just like having so
much fun for like five six seven eight
hours and then it's 2:00 a.m. and you're
just like all right time to go to bed
but it's a it's a really cool thing and
I like I guarantee you that I'm the same
way and I did not plan ever playing
video games or doing what I'm doing in
video games right now in my past it's
been so fun yeah we've made so many
great friends we the community
has been what's the best yeah absolute
best that has been probably one of the
highlights might just like we got our
skins in the game and like we've been
playing on it's very cool it's very cool
and like twitch just in and of itself
has given us so many cool opportunities
and it's cool to see cuz Genet like you
and I talk about each year we kind of
like have conversations about like okay
well what are we doing this year like
what's gonna be our project or focus and
we've talked about this a lot like you
know one year it was the podcast and we
birthed the podcast and we worked on it
and we were consistent and it was weird
and we didn't know what it was we didn't
really have sponsored but we just did it
that's our goal for that year I was her
goal for that year and we and we
finished the year we're like okay we did
this now it's Twitter yeah a year goes
by and it sucks then you can stop but
like we've been lucky enough to have
these experiences go well and feel like
we want to continue them and then it was
the than it was the twitch stream and
then it was you know we want to get a
house and look you know each year it's
cool to see that we're not and this is
largely in part and you are responsible
for being the planner of this because
you're really good at planning things
why thank you I'm a Virgo but that's not
something I ever did before I met you
eat was you know you make your new
year's resolutions and you're like oh
I'm gonna work out more I want to eat
better I want to travel all that you
know whatever but you like creating like
an actual idea in a plan and being like
okay that's what I'm gonna actually I'm
gonna attack this this you know I'm
gonna do it and having done it for a
number of years now and seeing the
fruits of those like then ventures kind
of just like around us it's very cool
well I feel like that's always sort of
been one of my strong suits is like I'm
very good at planning short-term and
executing my plan like I needed plan for
the day
I need maybe a plan for the week plan
for the month might be a little too far
a year five years very difficult for me
to do anything other than like it would
be nice to own a home someday you know
what I mean like not 100% sure how I'm
gonna get there but like I'm gonna try
my best but like executing short-term
goals I'm very good at you know and
that's what it takes sometimes just just
push through the [ __ ] day you know
get through the day do
things you want to do and then try your
best to plan long-term but if you can't
go with the [ __ ] wind blows you you
know what I mean yeah but like you can't
just sort of wake up and dilly-dally and
do whatever and nothing and you know
have no plan I'm not saying I have no
planner that we have no plan like we
have always had at least short-term
plans you know there are goals and yet
you just try your best to get those
things done and make a chain reaction of
those yeah a chain reaction is such a
good way to put it because like a lot of
the things that happen in your life are
caused by something else mm-hmm that you
didn't even plan on that kind of
happening and so like the idea behind
saying to yourself okay I'm going to
commit to doing something for the X
amount of time and I want to just hit it
full force and see what happens out of
it and even if that one thing doesn't
take off or succeed look you had
imagined or whatever maybe five other
things happen
even if you don't realize it indirectly
because of that and I think that is one
of the most important things about like
just chasing something you know you
don't know what what outside things
might come from that yeah and you might
not know till years later and you're
like thinking about it you're like damn
dude that only happened because I was
trying to make it twitch streamers and I
met this person I found this job
whatever that's how I feel about my
entire youtube channel as a whole like
not this year but maybe like last year's
when I started just like doing whatever
you know and it's been so satisfying to
watch well it's it's satisfying for now
for sure but like at the time it was
sort of like you know I'm just
it's YouTube's not the same and you know
I'm not quite sure what I want to do
with my content like it's it's I make
stuff that I like but like when I
started just doing things of what I
would call selfish content when I'm just
you know doing with things that I didn't
think that the internet wanted to watch
it was sort of my way of being like I'm
gonna bow out gracefully
so that if somebody logs on to my
channel they can just be like that [ __ ]
has lost her minds like we don't need to
[ __ ] care and I remember you like
kind of talking to me about this when it
was going on when you were first trying
to make those videos like it was its
first of all it's [ __ ] I can't even
imagine how terrifying it is for you to
be on YouTube at the level you are and
have been there for so long and just
make content for that many people it's
that's a
and I can't even imagine but I know you
deal with it well but you took that sort
of anxiety and you like you just like
really simplified everything I'm just
gonna make content that I [ __ ] want to
make yeah and yeah like it was I
remember you saying that like if people
were to come to my channel and see what
I'm doing they're like okay this is what
she's doing now piece and that's fine
you were at peace with that right which
is a cool thing because you didn't bow
out and people didn't leave well yeah I
mean that's that's what's been insane to
me within the last year or two years
it's like the fact that you know
something that resonates with you
personally like the most stupid things
you could ever imagine is like I want to
look like a chair or like someone asked
me to paint myself like a chair like why
would anyone really actually want to
watch that but like I don't know like I
was sort of just like doing the whole
like I'm gonna do whatever I want
because if if people are gonna leave and
not watch my channel like who cares like
I'm I'm okay at least you're not do it
on your turn I'm most like yeah like a
thirty year old woman on the internet
like it's okay if you don't stay like a
complete [ __ ] success your entire
[ __ ] life like who cares you know
what I mean like there's more to life
than just like having a popular YouTube
channel you know like like the the
podcast and the twitch stream like you
have other ways where you can make
content and exist and like have a good
time like I'm just trying to have a good
time just be creative as long as I can
you know what as long as you're doing
that like you're living the dream yeah
you know yeah you're doing what you want
to do and laughing and having fun like
that's the [ __ ] dream you know this
is the dream so I was like alright
people are gonna [ __ ] bounce out of
here like might as well just post what I
want posts you know what I'm saying yeah
it's been cool that's been cool to see
that so like yeah I don't know what's
gonna happen in 2019 I don't know what
my content is gonna be like at that
point but I mean for now it's been nice
but yeah I mean I was I kind of feel you
know I went through a similar like
process at least internally with myself
of like what is my content and like as
you know as my life changes and as I
grow up and as I get busy with other
projects and other platforms and
everything
what is my content what am I making and
I had to like think about that a lot
this year I feel like because for a
while I was like I didn't know what to
make I was like well I'm kind of past
the point of like doing this traditional
like here's what I'm doing look at me
like blogging you know whatever and then
you know I was kind of in this weird
like gray area of like well do I do I
make like sit-down videos or do I travel
or do I go shoot time lapses or do I
just sit at home Logging's weird
sometimes
it's weird it's super weird especially
because like you know there's like a
meta so to speak there's like a trend
all the time going on we're like certain
types of vlogs do well and you see them
all over the Internet and so that option
is always there okay I could do this and
I know it has X amount of like
guaranteed success or whatever and then
there's like okay what's your
bread-and-butter like what do people
like and can you have to weigh that in
but then there's like okay what the [ __ ]
do I want to do every day of my life
what do I want to I have this camera
what I want to document do i am i
miserable doing that and like i don't
know i saw this comment the other day
that kind of like stuck with me and it
was someone was just like your vlogs
feel a lot more lately in the last few
months or whatever like you're
documenting things in your life to show
to your kids in 50 years and like I
think that's dope but that's just what
it feels like as a viewer rather than
trying to entertain an audience you're
just kind of in a raw way documenting
what you're what you experience on a
daily basis and I think like even though
I'm not like thinking about that
consciously and trying to attempt to
make like a like you know like a photo
photo book book whatever you call a
scrapbook of my life in video form it's
nice to know that people can enjoy that
with me I don't know it's it's a weird
thing to do that like many many many
people can relate to is that like
sharing your life online is it has its
pros and cons it has its ups and downs
and it's just sort of a weird path that
we're all currently on those of us that
are on social media or the internet
because there's plenty of people that
just [ __ ] aren't you know but um it
gets weird and
chuckle and like taking time to think
about what it is that we consume and
what we share is like a complicated
subject that we're all sort of dealing
with for the first time let alone people
that make also have their like career
their relationship and all of that also
wrapped up into that is extra
complicated but like it's been a fun
year and I hope that we just like can
continue to keep having fun
in the years to come like I mean I'm
gonna take it a day at a time you know
yeah not trying to make any plans any
long-term plans that's not my forte
but like it's been a dream come true and
for those of you that listen to this
podcasts or watches on the twitch stream
or watch my channel watch Julian's
channel like it's really fantastic and I
think you know you said this about
twitch in the past too and we said this
about the podcast is like every time
that we sort of put our our energy into
you know something like this or like the
Twitter stream or my channel or Julian's
channel it just gives you a new way to
interact with people the way that having
a Twitter account is a different
interaction than your Instagram account
is different than your YouTube accounts
different than snapchat like it's all
different yeah and live-streaming has
been incredibly rewarding because it's
it's incredibly intimate it's an
intimate way to interact with people and
that has been so fun and different then
this has been which was different when
we started doing this video and you know
I hope you guys know that we're trying
our best to always like make things that
we want to make that are true to our
lives but are also just giving us a new
way to interact with you guys like I
think of all the people from twitch or
even Lee you know when we started the
podcast all the people that we met from
the podcast and then all the people when
we started twitch all the people that we
met from twitch is like it's really
overwhelming to think about the
relationships that didn't exist years
prior yeah and now we're seeing the same
names in our chat room and having
conversations with people every night
I'm saying like that's so wild and it's
it's yeah it's hard to imagine like
picturing this years ago it's just so
hard because like we livestream many
years ago on Ustream like you livestream
many years ago and like we did
together and it was like cool cuz we had
like this we called it the secret fam
and that's how the podcast started you
guys know and like it was cool but it
was nothing like twitches now who would
have thought like live like
live-streaming could have fed our brand
and our souls so much it made us feel so
fulfilled all the time
it really does it's really fun and it's
[ __ ] hysterical it's really fun to
interact with people alive it just is
it's like being in real life it is yeah
I feel I feel so social and antisocial
at the same time because I'm like
constantly talking to you guys and we're
constantly talking to our friends on
discord and gaming it's like so social
it's the point is is that it's a
liberation whereas when we started the
podcast this was the liberation because
all of the times and years when I felt
like if I had anything to say
I needed to jam it into a three minute
long entertaining video on my youtube
channel but now I have another outlet to
just sit and talk and like yeah you know
it's so liberating to do that and in the
twitch stream it's so liberating to just
like be live and have an opportunity to
just sit there and kick it and like not
even feel like you need to have anything
to say or talk about or do or you just
you're just sitting there you're just
live yeah you're just life and the
amount of like random conversations that
we've had or like conversations I've had
with chat based on like one thing I saw
and chatter one thing I said and I
reacted like you would never I don't
know it's like hard to imagine ever
having those conversations with your own
audience like is chocolate a candy bar
which is a candy chocolate cake not all
chocolate is candy Julian thinks the
only sour patch kids are candy oh you
candies that are chocolate for him but
it's not all chocolate is can you say
that I'm excited for 2019 I'm I'm you
know I'm always scared whenever you do
stuff like this obviously there's a
level of fear you don't have any job
security it's just you got to do the
best that you can so there's always a
level of fear but I hope we can continue
doing things and you know has has kind
of crazy
and unpredictable the Internet can be I
do feel pretty at peace with like moving
forward and continuing on to venture on
many different things and continue what
we're doing on the Internet
mainly because of you guys like you guys
are so welcoming of us and our ideas and
our different ventures like when we try
something new you're so behind it and
it's it's this like really comforting
feeling like maybe 90% of you guys will
leave eventually but the fact that there
are a few of you guys who are just so
[ __ ] invested in us and what we want
to do and appreciate when we try new
things or you know just experiment with
stuff it's a nice feeling to know that
like you have that you know like David
it's like with twitch man it's I don't
know the support it feels it feels it
feels like we're really lucky well what
I think is really cool about twitch too
and you know as YouTube has evolved over
the last 1012 years I think you know
it's a very telling sign that YouTube
has so dramatically and drastically
changed within that amount of time is
the fact that the YouTube rewind is now
the most disliked video on the Internet
that came out this year yeah this like
really shows the discrepancy of YouTube
their viewers the people that create
content like and YouTube itself you know
and we could talk more about that but
like there's nothing I can add to this
conversation that hasn't already been
said yeah the fact that it is the most
disliked video on the Internet I know
you to rewrite but I think that YouTube
as a platform has changed a lot yeah it
has become you know whether we like it
or not for good or for bad it has become
a place for people to make money for
brands to live for brands to make money
for commercials ads you know big
companies you know whenever there's a
pie full of cash you better believe
there's gonna be corporations and any
kind of people that can get their hand
in that pie they will be there you know
and it took a little while for them to
fully make their presence here but we
live in a place now where a scripted
vlog is a thing
you know not everything that you see is
completely just someone with their
camera you know making whatever they
want and twitch has been really cool
because it allows you to just directly
like interact and support people that
are people like you know they might be
assigned eSports player they might have
sponsors they may have some ads but like
that person and that was the gist of
YouTube and it still is at its core it's
like the people that you like you can
just actually support them personally by
giving them your time or watching them
and consistent they're consistently
there and like one thing that you talked
about for a while is the golden age of
YouTube like you described it like you
know everyone was supported the
community was small right like it was
like the early days of YouTube what
everyone felt like oh sorry I wasn't I
wasn't I didn't get to my point yet oh
sorry go ahead it's okay
no I go ahead I just I think that it's
interesting that we're living in a time
on this platform where all that exists
and you're still able to like we are we
have an independent podcast I have a
I've run my entire YouTube channel as
two years like there's no editors
there's nothing no one is there outside
of just us and we can exist in the same
space as a BuzzFeed that puts out videos
non-stop constantly just with a team of
huge yeah like it's interesting and I
think that in the future obviously it
gives people like us hope that you can
continue to be independent and create
content and you know not necessarily
compete or be unbelievably successful or
anything you know nothing like that but
that you can exist and still earn a
living and like be okay
in that space it's just like really
encouraging yeah you're not just gonna
be smushed by the big guy automatically
there's always a chance for you to do
something right and well you know I just
I think that it's really cool that it's
about to be 2019 I never anticipated
this part of my life to continue this
long and every year that I get to stay
and you know do what I want to do is
absolutely fantastic yeah it's cool 2019
I have one year left until my ten-year
high school reunion
hell yeah wait that is crazy
I'm not going I'm not going I didn't go
to mine I'm sick that week can I tell
you what happened to mine
oh you know when you elect your high
school class president it was part of
that person's responsibility our senior
year to organize your 10 year reunion
and it was all like yeah do you totally
[ __ ] do it
we get an email from him 10 years after
the fact he's like hey guys sorry I
didn't plan anything so uh just meet at
the otter lodge on Monroe Avenue at like
9:00 p.m. I guess we'll just kick it oh
that sucks
I wasn't gonna go anyways no I was like
this is [ __ ] rude I take back my vote
from 10 years ago you'll [ __ ] you
promised you vote for him yeah you
promise we're gonna have like a dope
10-year reunion damn you picked wrong I
need two wrong picked wrong you picked a
guy who was just gonna like flake ten
years later mmm he's late
I'm a hundred percent like one I'm sick
that week I'm gonna have a cold so
you're like right here like I'm [ __ ]
going on my ice cream why why you can do
it you can do I school was not the
dopest dude it was like I'm getting I
feel that I'm the spirit just left so
good not being there anymore mm-hmm
we drove by the other day and it's
totally different there's like so much
new it's beautiful
why couldn't I have the beautiful part
of it it's beautiful after I left not
when I was there but anyways what I was
saying about creating content and
supporting content creators I think it's
been really nice to as well as a
consumer of online media as much as we
make anything like making sure that I'm
putting my my views and energy and
effort towards people and things that
you know I like totally and the biggest
explosive piece of tea of 2018 for me
personally is that I I like to watch
jacksFilms Wow
it ended no they're all hate watches the
fair enough though I will say his Will
Smith grunt video was just so [ __ ]
incredible it was like the most internet
a beautiful piece of content I'm saying
and so long it was the best part of
YouTube rewind that video
Wow boy what is that T nothing city
yeah I mean I kind of feel like I'm
repeating myself a little bit but shouts
out to everybody who supports us on all
the platforms we are existing on the bus
next year I promise I will still not fix
the crooked pin rack in fact I might
even just tweak it a little more to the
side we also like we haven't made a new
project or goal for 2019 we haven't I
was thinking about out yeah and like I
don't know man
I'm just saying like tick-tock it's just
in there just one of my favorite things
of 2018 tick tock amazing all your
favorite it absolutely is ionic Lee
enjoy tick-tock I love it baby makes me
start with that prospect it makes you
that's not your favorite Beach it
doesn't matter
didn't love it it's like the same five
names yes honey but okay play your
favorite the good twenty it has
potential to have tenure fair enough ten
meme yeah it's hen shoot for the stars
you said it has five memes it has
potential to have at least 10 years no
like it is nice to see that sort of
humor returned in some form I agree that
I was completely fully 100% joking that
I want to attack tick-tock as a
platformer ourselves I'm not gonna do
that
I already profited all my tech ducks no
one can watch them anymore
they're gone but yeah uh we will see you
guys next year we hope you guys have a
really great break whatever you do with
your break your Christmas you know your
family your new years all of the above I
hope you have some time to turn off and
relax and enjoy yourself and rejuvenate
for the new year I think a lot of us are
excited for a new year yeah and I think
well the possibilities are endless
goodnight and goodbye times King sorry
yeah thank you guys for another year of
the podcast depend on everything else
you make us very happy and funny it's
been fun thanks for the memes thanks for
the left you guys are great we'll see
you guys
[Music]
[Music]